mokuba turns out for my nose tests
basketball making maintenance man I was
mine maybe a little fun como town so she
go continue to Archana like you the soil
candle thank you fo b for being my muse
oh yeah teach me how to make those
clutch shots like you Colbie oh there we
go Coby thank you anime and I have you
forgot no to quit basketball open how
are they show me your in the virgin
either she's an entire day chip about
India without her about meters from
where he got busted by the way who is
this kid doctor doctor for the
temperature no Carla doggone owner
remote iggy is Abner Scolari busca por
el Alami Kobe Bryant who knows Cora
college in San a mentally wouldn't even
help at my mas hay comida vamos extrano
buena suerte we've only just begun Kobe
thank you for making the purple and gold
look so good for all these years it's a
little cookie but it is such great
confidence
to me no handful of athletes are
synonymous with their sport and Kobe
Bryant is one of those people when you
think about basketball I want to be the
best basketball player I can do that
turns out to be the best basketball
player to ever live phenomenal icing on
the cake
you